hi my name is Jeremy Walker we're
continuing our talk on GES those are
Google developer experts who helped us
out with the api's again we have three
that came out for youtube and today
we're actually going to talk with the
one from all the way south from
Argentina Matthias and he's going to
tell us a little bit about what he's
been up to enjoy the show the eyes and
we're continuing our conversation with
our global YouTube developer experts so
next we have our veteran Matthias hi i
am from Argentina yet he covers South
America he's all over the place down
there thankfully for us and we were
talking a little bit about the Android
player API which for use that don't know
it's it's an API that allows you to play
youtube within your app but before I
jumped into that I'm going to talk about
something it's a little related you did
a phone gap code lab and so I wanted you
to talk a little bit about that in your
experience yes I tried to use the
YouTube naughty player inside a phonegap
up because phone job is is a good
framework to make a proof of concept
your fears up in a hug at home because
you can do that very fast and in my
first test I used a different player but
I believe that maybe the native player
is better for an Android app and i tried
to use the android a play multiplayer
using actually building a fungal plane
and I realized that is too much better
and the experience using the naughty
players is better than the evening
player great so you develop the phone
app developer out lab which by the way
is really great but you found it you had
to use the web view so you can make a
really quick head Hank hackathon like
type deal so the Android player API you
didn't actually use their but you were
saying sorry mr. you're saying that for
the comparison when you actually built
outside a phone app
with the Android player versus of
webview you found it a little bit easier
to use the Android player API yes iphone
that is a in my theories in 10 I used a
different layer because I made all the
up a with javascript I use the data API
to get recommendations but I believe
that the Android player service
experience so I try it and I I realize
that it is better yeah but you know the
phone I think thing was great it's a
great way to get people started in
Android and it may be the artist
experienced with Android development so
I guess when you were using the Android
player API did you have any future
requests that you would like yes because
it is a mobile scenario I believe that
maybe buffering or more buffering or
maybe offline a if you can manage the
video to play something in in an offline
scenario it could be great yeah so so
buffering is something we're always
improving and optimizing on from that
player API and then we've heard a lot
feature requests for offline so we know
that's a that's a big one from the
audience I'm it Matthias again thanks
for running around all of South America
for learning they do baby eyes and
thanks to the audience for joining us
and look for if you're in South America
look to see me a is talking about the
YouTube API thanks thanks
you